josh richardson is is an excellent
defensive player he's outstanding
defender but what we talked about in the
past you don't just says
luca gets the basket and the ham you
don't defend
steph curry one on one good transition
pick and roll
draymond green just stumbled and fell
and draymond green excellent defense
there
and the warriors like the other night no
player taller than six seven they've got
all their centers
out with injury as dachick knocks down
the three-pointer
the second game of four straight in
texas they'll play two against san
antonio monday and tuesday night
after the two here in dallas curry
trying to draw the foul count it and one
and curry with a chance for a four-point
play ubrae maybe got a hand on it first
curry goes back door nice fake and an
easy layup for steph curry
and a quick time-out call by rick
carlisle offensively
warriors get it going in transition
climb back into this ball game
nice drive from luke and doncic baseball
was all over him and dodged again with
that strength able to finish
third leading scorer on these mavericks
old for two to start that's a three
steph curry with his second
three-pointer
just past the midway point here in the
second
curry comes off the screen knocks down
the three there's that screen assist the
draymond dream talked about
so they just throw it in the post and a
good split screen
poor zing they are a fun team to watch
when they have it going
offensively curry
three-pointer that's good steph curry
with another that's his fourth
three-pointer
the help forces the switch and then gets
porzingis to moonwalk and knocks down a
long ball
get this in he and his wife aisha
organized a program to feed oakland
families
at the start of coronavirus of course no
one realized how long this pandemic
would last
porzingis now seven points the lead is
seven
curry three-pointer got it steph curry
once again he's got
22 here in the first half we still have
three minutes to play
initial defender richardson can't get
back into the picture before it's too
late
curry elevates that's beautiful and
tough talk to god
doncic that's what i was talking about
defensively so porzingis is up and it
forces curry to get rid of the
basketball so somebody else is shooting
beautiful sidestep from doncic
dallas's lead back to nine they led by
as many as 16. it was 18-2 to start the
game as curry gets a feed
from draymond green curry pass inside
deflected finds its way to green though
damien lee back out green cross court
curry another three-pointer trying to
draw a valley knocks it down
steph curry with his sixth three-pointer
here in the first half
away from the action so you think you
have a moment to just chill
you don't he's he's a threat at all
times on the offensive end
doncic three answers back
played here these two teams with 76-74
at halftime dallas
not quite as high but dallas has 70
again
curry puts it in steph curry from
downtown
we'll talk about steph curry lots more
got 30 mark
unbelievable and that was good defense
gotcha drives final seconds flips it up
and in
[Applause]
curry a three that's eight already he's
got eight threes
and if i'm on either side whether i'm
steve kerr or rick call out
i'm not happy with my team's defense i
mean the numbers that we put up
offensively
we should be in better position it's a
tough task
but it's a doable task where we can
force other guys to be the home run
hitters
as opposed to a proven one doncic
when he makes his three it's impossible
he's got deep range alice back up by six
largest lead was 16. that
was the opening minutes it was 18 to 2
mavericks to start the game
curry off the bounce layup that's good
38 now for curry
curry way downtown bang steph curry from
just inside half court
[Applause]
unbelievable that's his ninth
three-pointer of the game already
now drives gets inside back up top
draymond green
green back to curry fakes a two-pointer
a rare two-pointer that's good he's got
43.
a five-point dallas lead they've led the
entire game
curry another three puts it in 46 for
steph curry
and that's his 10th three-pointer here's
what i'm talking about the constant
movement i don't care about that action
recognize that it's coming back to him
you fall asleep you get screened a
little bit
all he needs is clearly the right call
doncic for three rattles it in luka
doncic with his fifth three-pointer
make you make a mistake defensively and
when you do
he's locked and loaded and when he what
did he realize in the absence i realized
how much i love the game
well he is loving everything tonight is
dachich puts in another 36 for doncic
[Applause]
curry dancing drives gets inside scoop
layup is good
48 for curry and a whistle and a foul
from deep and has this type of handle
switching a big on him
hesitation and then
hardaway drives trying to finish rebound
carms out
dodge it to another three it's good look
at doncic from downtown
and the lead back up to eight and a big
smile from dantich
love most leading his basketball team
unselfish play
competing on the defensive end
curry fakes trying to get that
three-pointer off drives gets inside
leia banks at home
51 for curry and the mavericks call
timeout it's a four-point game
game plan is to try to stop you and you
shred defense that must be an incredible
feeling this man
nachos gets in the paint floats it into
porzingis knocked out of his hands save
to cleba
clevela back out duncan three-pointer
bang
luca doncic from downtown and i like
this
doncic trying to track curry
curry fakes the three fires up another
three
bang curry with an answer and it's a
four-point game 38.1 remaining
will try and score quickly so they don't
have to foul on the
final possession curry on the drive gets
inside reverse banks at home
and the foul curry's fouled by cleba
and a chance to cut it to one steve kerr
is
as we see curry attack cleeba off the
switch
for the three-point play